hey everybody its Jesse I know it's been
a while it's been since new years since
I did a stream on free code camp so I'm
happy to be back and I have a new mic so
let me know how it sounds
everybody can hear me I actually got the
I got a nice upgrade here so this is one
of the yeti microphones so I saw a lot
of a lot of streamers using those that
good reviews so I figured you know I've
been doing this for a while maybe I
better upgrade and I was doing some
podcast lately and the audio quality is
obviously very important but today I
want to program something that's gonna
work with with this little headset this
is the let me see if I can get the logo
on plug it to neuro City notion headset
and so once we get it hooked up maybe
I'll try to put it on see what we can do
with it but the I did a video on my
channel kind of introducing what this
thing could do and doing a little demo
of it so if you're interested in
learning more about that particular
headset check out my my youtube channel
links in the description and you could
see it was one of like the last few
videos I did you'll see that one in
there
but today I want to actually code a an
app a react native app that'll run on on
mobile that will sync up with this
headset and allow you to do some stuff
so phase one of this app is gonna be
just just sync the device up and track
your focus and if you start to lose
focus we're gonna do something on the
phone so I haven't decided for sure yet
maybe vibrate the phone or make a little
noise something like that that's going
to be like the MVP phase one that I'd
like to actually get out on the App
Store after that I think it'd be cool
too
maybe add more features see if he could
make more things happen in terms of
focus I'd love to be able to have it run
on like Android auto so you could track
your focus while you're driving and get
an alert if you start to lose focus so
there's some some cool things you could
do beyond just focus
you can also train gestures so if like I
said check out the video if you want to
learn more about it but basically it's
possible with this device to think about
doing something like moving your arm
something whatever whatever you want to
think about and then trigger an action
so any action you could think of for
either something on the internet or an
Internet of Things
connected device so I'm hoping to do a
lot of cool stuff with this but first
step is we just need to get it hooked up
and working with an app and so that's
what we're gonna start with so basically
all I've done if you haven't seen my my
livestream before the idea is I it's
there's no prep work beforehand
I don't rehearse or you can do that much
research beforehand because I want it to
be as authentic as possible in terms of
what a developer would go through when
they're approaching new problems and
trying to solve things on the fly so I'm
gonna set a little timer we're gonna
code during the timer when the timer
goes off I'm gonna check the live chat
so there's a lot of activity in the live
chat and I just want to say hey to
everybody in the chat now and let you
know I'm not ignoring your questions I'm
gonna get to all your questions and
comments but I'll just get a code a
little bit first ok so I actually didn't
get my timer up beforehand so let me let
me do that now I'm gonna do that on
another screen now let me show you my
screen while I'm doing this there we go
now you don't have to look at me as much
after my time
I've lost my timer app
oh well I just need a moment where time
here I was using the Pomodoro timer that
somebody who used to watch the live
streams made and I had it up on my
screen but I closed it and let's do let
me just get give you the basics of what
I've done here in the code first all I
did was scaffold a project using Expo so
Expo is a way to use react native that
if you're not familiar with react native
react native is using javascript to
build Android and iOS and web apps right
expo helps you to do that it makes react
native easier to work with so I just
used EXO Expo I'm on this is pretty much
the latest version there might be some
minor versions after this but we're
pretty up-to-date if you hear noise in
the background that's my kids I have
four kids and they're all running around
so you may know eat your ice cream and
be good please take your sister fish
yeah you want to stay with me look once
you sit over there and you could watch
the livestream okay you're gonna do that
all right buddy
all right sorry about that my
five-year-olds really upset please go
upstairs my five girls very upset cuz no
no no they simply put her to go outside
with him so so all right so the tour is
I that's early I'll check oh react
natives we're using react native with
Expo and we were just going through the
package.json basically my my point of
going through this was I'm pretty sure
we're like pretty up-to-date on most of
the packages so we should be doing
pretty good with that we are using
typescript as well so typescript is
something you can use with JavaScript to
help have beat like a more strongly
typed version of JavaScript there's a
ton of info about typescript out there
so I'm not gonna take a ton of time to
explain it but basically like the
JavaScript you see might have a few
things that are different than normal in
there that's probably typescript
otherwise it works just like normal
JavaScript all right so let me slide
this over and just show you what I have
so far
I just took the boilerplate that expo
gives you that lets you run an app and I
added in some of this authentication
stuff now let me copy and paste in the
starter github repo into the chat so you
all can check out the github repo that
I'm gonna be pulling some code from and
I haven't put my code on github yet but
I will and I'll include that link in the
in the description so the the creators
of the neuro City notion brain computer
have already made a react kind of
getting started repo so it's for react
not for react native but I think we can
use it and make it work to authenticate
and be able to sync up our device with
with an app so that's where I pulled
some of this code from the the only
thing that I think won't work is so
they're using this local storage stuff
we don't have local storage on an app
right there's different storage so we're
gonna probably not be able to use that
otherwise I think we should be able to
reuse a lot of this code so I got
basically to the point where I needed to
put in some text inputs and that's where
I kind of stopped so we need the user to
input a little bit of data from their
device so everybody's gonna have a
different device ID and that they're
gonna need to use everybody who uses the
app so we need to provide them with some
some inputs all right and let's let's
actually run a version of this app let's
see if we can do so Expo lets you run it
I don't know if it's gonna let me run as
a web app
I don't want to run it on my phone
because I want you all to be able to see
it so let's see if I can run this w yep
there we go so it didn't list it as an
option but if you hit W you can open it
as a web app so let's see if it'll it if
it'll run I may have messed it up when I
copied and pasted this though yeah and I
did so let me pull this over just show
you so we're getting an error because of
that local storage stuff so let's take
that out we can keep this in so these
are react hooks right so we can keep
this in and just say you state and
instead of device ID let's go let's just
give it an empty string for now and we
have this what is this navigate thing
here let's comment this out for now and
as I said we don't have a device ID so
okay this is covered and we need to get
rid of this subscription set user or set
you okay
all right let's see if we can at least
get it to run all right cool so we got
it to run so you can see let me make
this bigger so that's the text that we
have so we actually have this app
running now we're running it in the kind
of web mode so it's not exactly the same
as running it on a mobile device but
it's gonna give us a good idea
without having to go through everything
about like running a mobile simulator
it's gonna give us a pretty good idea
what our app is doing at least to be
able to say like does it even did it
even work am I getting like crazy errors
so that's a good start but we need the
user to be able to put in some data
right so we need the device ID that's
probably the most important thing and
yeah so we definitely need a text input
for device ID ID so you can see I've
already pulled in text input from react
native react native comes with a bunch
of components like by default so we're
gonna put in a text input down here so
instead of this text that we just saw
let's throw in a text input and we could
change this text to say link your notion
the headset is called the notion headset
and let's put in a text input and you'd
like that let's look up what all the
props are that go into a text input
right so let's go back to our
or chrome here and let's look look up
react native takes input and in about
about 15 minutes I'm gonna go back to
the chat and read a bunch of stuff so if
you're if you're in the chat commenting
I will definitely get to those comments
and I don't intend to ignore the
comments there we go it's just the react
native documentation and this will give
us just a little example yeah actually
let's just copy and paste this example
and that'll give us a good place to
start hey Ambrose you don't dribble
basketball while I'm doing this cuz I
make a lot of noise okay buddy thank you
alright so I'm not going to mess with
the style yet I'm not that worried about
the style this that first we're just
gonna try to get this working and then
we can make it look nicer to be honest
I'm going for kind of a really minimal
interface anyway but we have on change
texts but in this case what I want to do
here is add the device ID so if we look
at our hooks up here we have set device
ID as our hook so we're going to change
this to set device ID and now every time
a user types in here it's gonna give us
it's gonna change the state for this
component the device ID state and for
the value we're gonna put in device ID
okay so what this will do for us is this
makes this input now what we call a
controlled input or controlled component
because the value is now controlled by
our component State
so the value is the state and when you
change the value of the input it updates
state let's save it and see if it see if
it worked
let's go back here yep
and look we have yeah that and if we
check so let's let's inspect this and
see if we can see the state updating
I'll make this a lot bigger we should be
able to see the state updating for good
find our root component
[Music]
maybe it's app yeah all right so here we
go here's our state and we can see as
the type the state changes so it's
working these that that's working great
now our let's go back to our code let's
see what we need to send so a user all
right so if we make a to create a new
notion all we need is the device ID so
we may be able to test that out right
away that's not about our user set user
so we're getting the user from subscribe
here so we don't need it to input the
user so we may be able to try it out to
see if we can sync this device well
let's give that a shot all right cool
so we're gonna need to change the code
just a bit though so if there's a user
we set user I want some type of
indication though that this is actually
working so let's add in a little bit of
text here and say if user then let's
render a little text it says
login that way we'll know it worked so
what this is doing is it's checking that
state for user which should be empty
let's double check that so user is now
is set to null at first but if we
successfully login with our device then
we should be able to subscribe and get a
user and then that will set the user
then down here will detect that there is
a user and we'll say okay now let's
display the text logged in so if you're
not familiar with react or react native
this might be a little bit confusing to
you feel free to ask some questions I'll
try to explain as much as I can in about
10 minutes I'm gonna take a break and
look at the questions here but let's
give this a shot now if I miss something
I'm sure it'll throw an error and we can
we can fix that but for now I think we
have let me give it a save here just
verify that that's working okay great
oh yeah I know what we need we need a
button we need some sort of button to
submit this right okay so let's add in a
button and react native actually has a
button well let me import it here so
let's import button
so you have this button and I guess we
could check let's check the
documentation for this so we'll search
for we're already in here buttons right
there let's copy and paste the example
for button
there we go so it's gonna say press me
and then it's gonna run this alert but
we don't want the alert
what we want is on press we want it to
run this this use effect so what we'll
do is let's just grab this code yeah I'm
gonna grab this code I'm gonna comment
this out because we're gonna want it to
behave like this at some point but for
now we just want it to say see we'll
just call it login whoops a login and
we'll make this an arrow function and
let's paste in this code it's not
working
let's get rid of that waiver to that
part okay
lotion
let's do this as the cause lotion equals
no and then that way we can set notion
here about that whoops let's motion
maybe
are we declaring it oh okay
know what happened there okay so you
already have notion as a state let's
back up a little bit why is it giving me
this because I got too many brackets
that's why there we go
okay so now we have a login function
that should get us what we need here and
we just need to call it on press there
we go yeah all right so we're gonna we
saved it let's try it out
loading I mess something up oh yeah
why is it saying loading if loading
that's why it's saying though all right
let's
let's just set loading to false for now
there we go okay I need to get my device
ID so on another screen I'm gonna grab
my device ID see if I can
find it I thought I had it up already
but there we go
and actually let me move this over real
quick I'm not really sure if I'm
supposed to show my device ID or not
but I know how to fix that let's do this
I'm gonna set the width to five so check
this out
so the width of my text input is five so
when my pace my device ID in uh
everybody saw it anyway oh whoa I'm not
that worried about it I just want to see
what error were getting could be if this
is not working we should get an error
I'm getting nothing
am I getting anything in the network
what's going on nothing
alright let's throw in some console logs
so first thing I want to see is is our
login function even being called at all
so let's say console log I'm just gonna
put in a little string there just to see
what's happening alright
hey there we go we got something this
time oh nice so it did run and we got
errors so we got illegal app name from
firebase check our network here
interesting
yeah so it looks like it's trying to do
something
so that's a good that's good progress
right all right good progress I'm also
gonna check my timer cuz it's got to be
just about time for taking questions
here yep
about a minute I'll stop and answer some
questions and at this point it looks
like new notion device a deceleration
oh I know let's check our state let's
see if we got anything back because I
wonder if if we're getting an error on
this part or if we're getting an error
on this part so let's see if the state
updated at all good or components here
and one of these hooks is the state that
we're looking for so let's paste that in
cool look at that alright awesome so we
got our we got our stuff here we got our
response there at least we got something
right so I believe then our error would
be in the in that second part that we
saw right so this is happening we're
setting all the data we get back after
we do this
or being set here then this is running
and we're trying to subscribe and get a
user right but something's happening
there so let's take a little break I'm
answer some questions and then we're
gonna come back and see if we can figure
out what else we need to do here at this
point it might not be a bad idea to go
look at the the demo react code provided
by neuro City the the people who make
the headset and see what they did
because I know I didn't copy and paste
everything over and I bet that there's
some other stuff happening that we need
to do to make that work
it's so I need to we make the text on
the chat a little bigger so I can see
there we go okay all right for everybody
who just joined as well I'm gonna use
this brain computer interface I did a
demo video kind of an intro to this
brain computer interface device on my
channel so check the link in the
description to go to my channel and then
you will be able to find that that video
on a brain computer interface and get
kind of an overview of what this thing
is and what it can do and let's see I'm
kind of just strolling through the chat
right now looking for questions a couple
questions about what language you're
using this is react native and the
language is JavaScript with typescript I
have a question about for cybersecurity
what is best B Tech in CS or I T tell
you the truth I don't I don't really
know if anybody out there is in
cybersecurity and can answer that
question we're kind of wondering what
type of degree is best for cybersecurity
let's see hi I'm from the Philippines
it's a great feeling to see you code
here thanks for sharing oh you're
welcome thanks for saying that that's
awesome
Michael wall says ceh for ethical
hacking is an option okay that's cool
what is that certified ethical hacker I
believe there's the ceh Lonnie said it
was too close up so I had a video of my
face at the beginning is too close up I
will remember that maybe I will back up
a bit
next time code dragon says learning a
lot from your channel that's awesome
that's awesome there's a lot of good
content here on the free code camp
channel a lot of a lot of really smart
people contributing so I mean my live
streams it is what it is right but
there's some really even if you don't
care for what I'm doing right now check
out the other videos there they're
really good
rod says it would be great to see more
live coding videos on the free code camp
Channel I'm really gonna try to do some
more live coding I used to do it a lot
more I gotten away from it and had a lot
of stuff happening with my job so I'm
I'm not able to work from home as much
as I used to be able to have some health
issues going on but I think I got that
all worked out now and hopefully and so
I'm gonna try to get on a better
schedule so I can live stream or Jeff
says thanks for coding lives so we can
all watch this is awesome you're welcome
thanks for watching college asks what do
we use react for exactly
okay so react is a library that helps
you build web apps I think it's some of
its strengths at least from my point of
view are making state management easy
it's once you kind of learn it it's it's
it's pretty simple to kind of think
through the flow of state so I like it
for that and there's a lot more to react
but basically it just helps you build
web apps react native uses kind of the
same concept the same logic but then
lets you apply that to mobile apps
not found says what will the back end be
built in so neuro City the company that
makes the the brain computer interface
has their own kind of back-end for
handling like the the data that's coming
from the headset so we're gonna take
advantage of what they're providing and
then we won't at least in the stage one
we won't need our own back-end as we add
later functionality that's something we
might need to talk about and think about
but I'm not 100% decided on what what
exactly we would need and what we would
use for that I see I'm getting to the
point in the chat where all my kids came
in and so thanks everybody you're saying
the kids are cute yeah that's the real
for a while I got to tell you I wanted
to stream more but I was a little bit
embarrassed by my setup and I know it's
silly because if you've watched me
before you know I've done a ton of
stream so my setups always been not that
great but I got just I'm in a basement
and the the quality in terms of like
audio is probably not great because my
kids and everything going on but then
they'd find it hit me and it took me way
too long to realize this but you know
that's if I want my stream to be
authentic in how it really is for me to
code then I should just leave all that
stuff in so I decided just to go for it
and you know in stream with all the
distractions and everything built in so
hopefully everybody kind of understands
that you know this is not like a
professional thing that I'm doing it's
just a little side thing so there will
be distractions and noise Carlos says
this is the most authentic life you have
ever seen subscribing now and that's
awesome
all right
our ROV
says where can we get that brain device
so if you look up neuro City let me let
me give you the link actually let me
give you the link to their website and a
double check and I have the right link
and then I'll paste it in let me paste
that link in for you all this is the
website for the neuro City headset I
believe you can join I think there's
like a waitlist right now but you can
join that and see about getting it
getting the headset
okay
all right so I'm going to go back to the
code now and do a little bit more code
and let's see looks like someone in the
chat using some some language so I'm
gonna hide that users messages let's see
so anyway hopefully you all didn't see
that I think I think most of the
messages were hidden by the filter but
somebody was not being nice so
I'm a double check and then I get
everything
all right cool anyway sorry it took me a
couple minutes to catch that I try to
keep everything real positive I see it
might be somebody else
and I think I got all the the people
causing trouble so anyway on my channel
in on the free code camp Channel I try
to keep everything positive so if you
got if you want to be negative there's
so many places on the internet you can
just go and talk trash if you want to
this is not the place for that
so try to keep everything encouraging I
don't I don't mind if you want to
criticize what I'm doing in terms of my
coding abilities or my ability to
livestream that's fine I don't mind that
but I don't want you calling anybody
else names in the chat so if you do I'm
I'm not gonna make a big deal I'm just
gonna hide all your messages so anyway
hopefully that's that's through and we
can get back to some code so yeah let me
get back to some code here I probably
right maybe go for like another half an
hour so and then I'm gonna I'll stop
streaming so you know I don't wanna it
is the weekend I want to spend time with
my family so I figured I just take about
an hour to do some some code and then
you know we you know we won't finish
today on this app but you know me I'll
give it another shot later in the week
and see if we can get it get it finished
so what I'm gonna do now is we're gonna
go to this this repo let me make it
bigger so this is just on github so I
already put a link to this in the chat
if you weren't here I'm gonna link it
again and there we go
so if you want to check it yourself that
links now in the in the live chat but I
want to go in here and see this is like
the reacts that called their react
starter right so we do need to change
some things though because this is react
native so I'm gonna go in here to the
source and let's check out their app j/s
and see if we're missing something
important
I assume that we're missing something
important that's why it's not working so
I'm gonna make this a little bigger I
just wanna make sure everybody can see a
little bit bigger
that's might be a bit too big but better
to be too big than too small in terms of
visibility so somebody may be watching
this on their phone so now I know like
so we have these right so we have this
we're good we did comment this out
I see so they're doing some navigation
so they're navigating to some other
components so that might be part of the
piece that we're missing but let's say
let's keep reading this is the user to
return just try to set the user okay
okay so they're using react router and
they have this login which is basically
what what we're doing is the login
screen for the most part and they're
passing the login screen this info okay
so let's check out and see what kind of
logic they have going on in their login
screen you see if we're missing
something let's go back to our source
we'll go into I guess pages login
oh I see so they're saying they get an
email password
so it looks like we need a little bit
more is we need to email the password so
they need their their prompting people
for the email and password so we're
definitely gonna need to do that so
here's what I think is probably
happening with their app and should
happen is that the after they do the
part that we did then the user is
prompted for more info so that's the
next part that we have to that we have
to do so I guess
let me make this a little smaller so I
can get it kind of a big picture what's
happening might be able to just copy and
paste some of this stuff
find what we actually need here
so we need so this is notion dot login
okay
all right I think we need to add an
email in password field and we need to
add in State for email and password as
well so I'm just gonna grab this first
and I'm gonna try to do it all in one in
one page for now in one file just for
like simplicity down the road we may end
up like breaking it out into different
files different components and let's
grab this use effect
we'll put it down here and we're gonna
have to get rid of some of it but it
should work for now let me see if I need
something else I think we're good at
least for now good as to the next step
at least so we don't need that I don't
need that and I don't need that and I'm
not gonna do this because I'm just gonna
console on the air okay
all right so this use effect will only
run if some of this data changes right
so
we may not we may actually not want it
like this basic function you may want to
change let's change the name of our
function let's just change it to in it
for like initialize to this button is
now gonna be initialize okay and we'll
do it like this
let's do
let's let's make more text boxes here
that know how we should do this yeah you
know let's just make some more text
inputs to get all the data we need so
we're going to add two more text inputs
and instead of device ID it's gonna be
set email
email and then we're gonna say set
password and the value will be password
so this is going to give us three text
inputs now and they're gonna be linked
up with our new state so the first text
input is going to be device ID next one
will be email and the next one will be
password all right so we're gonna have
these in there now and let's save it
just to make sure we haven't broken
anything yet nope we got all three of
these and I got them real skinny like
this just so that it's not too obvious
what my password and stuff is so okay
now on press me we're not actually doing
anything but let's let's change that
we're gonna change the logic a little
bit here so currently on Annette we're
getting this new notion right and we're
setting notion and then this use effect
works and we're trying to set the user
so we're subscribing and we're trying to
set the user here when we get the user
actually what we could do there is email
password wage
did they have their their own their own
version of it user
I'm actually gonna I'm gonna comment
this out for now because
I think the login let's go back and look
at our
Abdo j/s again and see what we had so
if user Elsa navigate I see so we took
some of this stuff out I believe this is
what I believe is happening so if you
can't get a user it navigates you to the
login page and then you have to log in
so log in needs to happen first in so
the set user is being passed down as a
prop so we're we're good we're actually
good in the way we're doing this in that
we the next step is this step here and
so I just want to make sure this runs
only when we want it to run so these I
guess
I guess who were as long as we enter
everything in properly I think this
should work okay I think it should work
at least to get us in the next step now
what I want to do is figure out what my
password is that I'm supposed to put in
here so let me go back to I'm doing this
off screen just to hide I guess what it
but this is oh I know I know now so the
way this works is I put in my device ID
and my email and I should get an email
with my password in it I think that's
how it'll work
let's double-check
you know we could do we could just clone
this guy already fort this maybe I did
let's for kiss a clone it run it then
we'll know what the flow is supposed to
be from a user perspective I'm going to
clone it and we'll just go right in here
and clone it from here I'm going a git
clone now I should have this available
so let's look at my projects folder and
see there's a notion react starter so
let's CD into notion react starter I'm
gonna open up a new vs code window and
then I'm gonna go back to the right
folder here so I don't accidentally mess
things up confuse them stay focused all
right now let's go to our other vs code
window and just run this really quick
we'll do a new terminal let's run and
the NPM I so that will install
everything
oh that's not i wondered why that
package.json was so long accidentally
clicked the package left JSON good so
this is once this installs we'll just
run it there we go NPM run start
cool oh I see all right so they have see
we were we weren't really that far off
this is kind of what our screen has on
it it doesn't look like it but it it has
this so device ID email and password all
in one go interesting but how am I
supposed to get the pass
let's go back here and see
let's check our dogs
make it a little bigger all right
web let's see the web app
all right device ID email password
hmm maybe it wants the password that I
use yeah I'll give it a shot I'm
thinking it wants the password that I
use for like to actually log in to the
notion so let's try that see you again
so I'm gonna grab the device ID and I'm
gonna turn my device on and I'm gonna
put in my email and then I copy and
paste my password or at least what I
think the password would be
[Music]
let's see what happened
wrong password hey cool like we get they
get farther in the process all right let
me try a new password
wait did that work that really work I
think it did
all right it's cool let's check out
yeah okay so this
nice it worked
sweet sweet sweet sweet all right cool
all right so that worked I didn't really
expect that to work so quickly so what's
the next step
hey let's go back to the code here the
next step it's alright so now I guess we
can say we subscribed with the user
[Music]
or do we already have you I think we do
I think we've said yeah we've
authenticated we've set the user yet cuz
what's the second hook the second hook
is user so we we saw that data we have
that data now so the second hook here we
have cool so since we have that we can
look now it kind of like the next step
so we have our code here let's see what
we do next
what's our comb stage so doing a
subscription now the subscription that
they're doing here is this notion comb
subscribe to calm we want to subscribe
to focus so I think we can just
let's grab some of this here yeah let's
grab this and bring it in all right so
I'm gonna pull this in here so what we
should get then is everywhere we say
calm I'm going to change it to focus
focus all right so we're gonna subscribe
to the focus and for this I'm actually
gonna let me put this on okay so you can
actually get some real brainwaves see if
I can fit my headphones on top of it I
actually can that's cool it's not very
comfortable with these big headphones
alright cool so what I want to do I
guess is I don't want this to be
actually yeah this could be a use effect
so we'll just do it like that so this
use effect will say yeah if there's no
user or no notion then it's just gonna
return right but if we have both of
these then we're actually gonna run this
we're gonna get this this focus it's
gonna be a number and we want to display
that so instead of this logged in I want
to display focus alright in react if I
put brackets in there then I can run
JavaScript inside so this is gonna give
me not the word focus but the value of
focus in state so let's save that I'm
gonna have to put in all my so that
currently we're not saving any of the
data so I'm gonna have to log in again
but bear with me for a second while I
get all this login stuff in again
I said I work did it did that not save
didn't work this time what did I mess up
first argument was invalid comb SEC home
what the heck I thought we'd get rid of
all the comb stuff didn't we we did why
is this so China set comb
oh look at that alright so my column
score right now is 0.51 cool let's see
if I can
yeah there we go so it's updating so I
lost focus there did you see me I looked
over there and lost focus so this is
giving me a real-time focus score
basically like how focused I am right
now that that is pretty cool so this is
yeah cool so I want to show you let me
show you the screen so like this is the
developer kind of console thing so you
can see this is focus right it's like
tracking my focus levels so like a
higher number means I'm more focused
this is between zero and one so what
we've done here let me see if I get
split screen it yeah there we go
so like these focus numbers it's it's
right now it's reading the same feed so
I guess like we've we've succeeded now
successfully connecting this to a react
native app so I'm getting data from this
brain computer interface headset it's
going out to the neuro city servers
right and then they're providing this
API that I could subscribe to in my app
that's giving me this this data so now
we're getting real-time data about my
level of focus in my brain in this react
native app so that's pretty sweet the
next step then would be a Alex who built
he's the co-founder of neuro city is
watching the stream so awesome glad to
have you here so so like right now
essentially like it works right we can
connect this into react native the next
step
would be it's kind of a pain to have to
login every time right so it'd be nice
if we could save this data somewhere
locally on a user's machine so that
it'll auto log you in so I'd say that's
probably the next step that I'd like to
do because that would really help save
time because it you know it just takes a
while to keep copy and paste in that
every time we do something new and make
a change so that's probably the next
step that I'll do in in the next stream
because I think yeah so I'm over the
hour mark and I only wanted to take in
an hour I don't want to take too much
time away from my family here on on a
Sunday so on the next stream will work
on saving this in whatever version of
local storage we need so on the web it
would be the browser's local storage but
on an iOS or Android device that would
be different so we need to make sure we
code it so that it'll work on whatever
platform we're running on so that it'll
save that information so we don't have
to log in every time then we can try to
figure out some thresholds and say like
alright let's say if I drop below a 0.2
then it's gonna do something right
vibrate make a noise flash the screen
it's going to do something to warn us
that our attention is dropping below the
threshold that we set so I say that's
that's probably a good a good next step
also I think I would kind of want to use
maybe like a simulator right to make
sure we can simulate what's happening on
a on a mobile device so I can run it on
my mobile phone but it'd be harder for
you to see it I guess I could hold it up
to the camera but I'm gonna see if I can
maybe get like an Android simulator
running for the next time so we could do
this also so Alex and the chat says you
could use react native a sink storage
library which that's a great a that's a
great suggestion I actually contributed
to
the late the new version of react native
async stories so I don't think it's out
yet so if you use the react native
community a sink storage package the the
latest like development version has a
bunch of contributions that I did to get
it to work with local storage in the
browser so I'm actually I'm kind of
proud of that because that was a lot of
work and I did do some live streams
about that too so I think I put that on
my channel if anybody's interested in
how that works but all right cool so I'm
just gonna leave this up on the screen
for now just to kind of see like all the
all the data go in here
I'll leave I'll leave this as well and
then let me go back to the chat I'm
gonna get through the chat kind of
quickly as it because I want to I don't
want to stream too much longer I wanna
get back to my kids here but I do want
to answer some of your questions so I'm
gonna try to stream to answer questions
if I don't get to something put it in
the comments and I'll try to get to it
you can definitely like shoot me a DM on
Twitter or something if you want to if I
don't get your question but I'm gonna
try to get to as many as I can
the genius marketer says do you
recommend w3 schools or what to get some
code if you're if you're trying to learn
how to code check out free code camp so
it's free code camp org they've got an
awesome curriculum people have gone
through the free code camp curriculum
and have gotten jobs and stuff so I
would definitely definitely check that
out whenever my my focus stops maybe I
move too much I don't know what I did
but
this one's still working but yeah
definitely check out free code camp
that's that's a great place to go
Tom William says his react native normal
JavaScript er type script you can use
react native with normal JavaScript or
type scripts I chose to do it with
typescript but you definitely could do
regular JavaScript I just kind of
recently got into typescript I've been
using it at work so I'm trying to trying
to use it more just can't really learn
it well but you definitely don't have to
use it
let's see
I see some of you were trying to share
your email addresses and it got blocked
by the filter so I just I showed that so
if you scroll back up in the chat those
are visible now so you should be able to
get them you know now all right there's
a lot of cool discussion about
programming languages in the chat so I'm
not gonna read it all out but I love it
whenever there's great discussion from
from you on the chat no-beard says I'm
hearing footsteps on the floor yeah
those are my kids playing upstairs I
actually had a contractor come in and
look and talk to me about maybe getting
a like a soundproof office to do these
videos in and they're supposed to get
back with me with an estimate I kind of
expected it sooner I don't know what's
taking so long but hopefully I can get
like a legitimate kind of recording
studio at some point and then should be
a little bit better audio quality for
these videos
hey Christa Mars is here how's it going
Chris Chris de Mars has a cool podcast I
did an episode on recently it's called
tales from the script so check that out
on I think it's it's on Spotify I listen
to it through Google podcasts so yeah
check that out I'm sure it's available
in all the different podcast services
but yeah he does he does a great job
yeah Chris I'm I'm doing good I was just
doing a little bit of coding I'm kind of
wrapping it up oh yeah that's true and
Alex who was he was on the chat he's the
co-founder of neuro city was also on the
podcast as well so you can learn more
about neuro City and the brain computer
interface what you're trying to do and
learn a little bit more about me if you
want if you check out the podcast so
yeah Chris Chris just put in the chat
he's on Spotify Google podcasts Apple
podcast stitcher so all the podcast
things yeah check check him out we got a
question from big dot it says I I got an
exam in six months high school level and
C++ for entering a college do you think
I stand a chance I started learning C++
like two months ago but is there enough
time you definitely have a chance you
know it's hard to say like how long
it'll take anyone but you know kinda
depends on how much time you have to
study but I you know don't don't quit on
it I think you have a chance you know if
you study art at it you know especially
if it's high school level I don't I
don't really know what they would expect
a high school student to know but if you
have six months left and you've already
been studying for two months I think you
you got a good chance at doing well on
the test I don't know I'd like to hear
other people's opinions on this I I
haven't done any C++ code except I took
one C++ course a long time ago maybe
like early 2000s but I don't remember
that much from it so probably not the
best to ask about C++ but I definitely
think you could do it
Omar says sir you are awesome
Thanks I appreciate that Isis thank you
for your wisdom and time I have no idea
how to code but I respect people who
share their knowledge thank you yeah
you're welcome welcome I'm happy to
share it and yeah hopefully you all get
something out of this no beer says
what's up Jesse it's been a while for
streaming how are you I'm doing all
right I I know it's been it's been a
while I am to tell you the truth like
I've had I had some weird health issues
recently that were kind of just like
keeping me from doing a lot I I had like
some scans done on my lung and they
found some like black like shading like
in the scans and turns out I had like
nodules on my lung and I kept doing all
these tests I couldn't figure out what
it was so I wasn't that worried about it
but it got me thinking like a if this is
some serious I want to spend as much
time with my kids as I can so I kind of
stopped on any side projects or
streaming your stuff and but it turns
out I just saw a lung specialist this
last week I don't think it's anything
threatening he thinks that I have like
allergies and asthma and I found out I
have sleep apnea so like I got a lot of
stuff figured out but the good news is
none of it is life-threatening
right it's all it's all fine so now I'm
hoping like I'm hoping to be able to get
back into streaming more because I
really love doing this and I miss you
know we we kind of had like a crew of
people that would watch all the time and
you know I missed that so anyway thanks
for asking and you know I'm gonna try to
i'ma try to do my know I say this all
the time but I'm gonna try to do my best
to stream more either either through
free code camp or maybe do some videos
on my channel I think I'm gonna
alternate a little bit but I definitely
want to do this more and I'm having a
lot of fun with this brain computer
interface thing too this is kind of
really cool and different than what like
my day-to-day work
let's see Dylan says I don't get what
you're trying to do basically I'm
linking up for right now for what we did
in this and this should show I'm linking
up this brain computer interface that
I'm wearing with a react native app so
that we can get data from this device
into the app we're gonna do some cool
stuff with it but for right now we've
just succeeded at getting the data so
this little number we see here is actual
like score on a scale of 0 to 1 of how
focused I am right now
oh cool Kristin Moore says that they did
a blood test and everything came back
good then you were good yeah I'm not
like I said I'm not worried pretty much
got everything figured out I got to do
some more tests and this week because
there was some stuff with my liver that
the doctor was worried about but to be
honest with you I've been trying to work
out a lot lately and I'm taking all
these supplements and I think that was
throwing off my blood tests a little bit
so this whole week I've been taking off
and just basically not working out not
taking any supplements and I'm gonna
redo the tests and see if that helps I'm
expecting it will and then at that point
I think basically everything that that
was wrong with me will be at least
explained but yeah I think should be
good I feel good and so I figured I feel
good I feel in good shape the only thing
that was weird for me was I kept getting
out of breath really easily but it makes
sense a 5 asthma that totally explains
it so I mean at all like that it all
makes sense and and I feel good so I
have like an inhaler now that I could
take if I feel out of breath so I'm
gonna test it out probably you know
maybe next time in the in the gym I'm
gonna take my inhaler with me and then
see if I like it do my normal workout
and then see if I feel
difference I'm expecting I'll probably
be able to breathe a lot better but
anyway I know some of you probably care
about that and some of you were just
here for the code so I'm not gonna talk
about it anymore
like y'all can ask me on social media if
you want but anyway yeah I'm gonna wrap
things up now and go hang out with the
kids a little bit before before bedtime
and yeah it was really good I'd love to
keep going with this project and some
future streams let me know what you all
think in the comments if you have
questions you know shoot them in the
comments to me or Twitter or Instagram
or whatever social media you like my DMS
are open I'll get back to you as soon as
I can
and yeah so until next time like have a
great rest of your weekend great
beginning to your week and I'll see
y'all later